we've been talking all morning about
protests around the country after the
release of video showing Memphis police
officers beating Tyree Nichols the 29
year old father died three days later
from his injuries that night according
to an independent autopsy and five
police officers have been fired and are
now charged with second-degree murder
CBS News contributor Ibrahim X Kendy
argues that anti-black racist ideas
produce a total disregard for black life
his new book how to be a young
anti-racist is meant to empower teen
readers to do something about that by
helping to create a more Equitable world
he teamed up with Nick Stone to
reimagine his best seller how to be an
anti-racist for young adults if remix
candy is the founding director of the
Boston University Center for anti-racist
research and Nick stone is the New York
Times best-selling author of dear Martin
and clean getaway and they join us first
on CBS mornings thank you both for being
here we do have to start with the very
sad news what we saw on Friday and then
the reaction over the weekends peaceful
protest but understandable anger Abram
you've called it a total war on black
people explain that
well black people have among the lowest
life expectancy in the United States
and you know what's one of the leading
causes of death for young black men
police violence and and so there's a
leading cause one of the leading causes
of death for for young black men like
like Tyree Nichols and so for me I just
want for wants black people to live and
racism to die
Nick what was your reaction
mother so I have two sons how old are
they they are six and ten and it's
shocking still which I'm honestly
thankful for because I do feel like
there are a lot of people who are
getting desensitized to things like this
so the fact that I was shocked that I am
angry and sad I think is is good and
feeling those emotions like we all need
to give ourselves the space to feel
those those uncomfortable emotions a lot
of the conversation is circling around
that the officers were black and the
young man was black and they and people
keep going back to the dehumanization of
this young of Tyree Nichols how do you
explain that coming from other black men
or is that something that can be
explained Ibrahim I think it can be
explained the most dangerous racist idea
is the idea that black people are
dangerous and it's an idea that anyone
can internalize anyone can believe
including black people including uh
black black police officers and so when
you when you tell black officers or any
officer that those people are dangerous
go into those communities and keep us
safe these are the things that are going
to happen but you're one of those people
though that's why people are struggling
with this but you are one of those
people and I think that's the
insidiousness of racist ideas that's why
it's so harmful
so talking about how to combat them and
turning to the book how to be a young
anti-racist Nick I've always been
curious how pairings happen on a book
like this right how his work gets
adapted and by whom in this case if I
have this right you dm'd him on
Instagram
okay so why do you want to do that and
then Abram like how did it work why what
did you say number one what did you say
well I I asked flat out I said you know
if you ever decide you want to do a
young reader's Edition of how to be an
anti-racist like stamped was done for
stamp from the beginning you know
consider me as a person who could adapt
um it worked yeah it did you've got the
credentials for it did it take you more
than two seconds to say yes it really
did it you know Nick Stone I mean her
her best-selling work her voice her
connection to young people I wanted this
book the voice of this book to be to be
targeted to our to our youngest readers
what was the story you both wanted to
tell
well I I wanted young people to be able
to understand what they're experiencing
young people are experiencing racism
they're trying to make sense of it you
have you have young white kids who are
being targeted online by white
supremacists you have teens of color who
are facing multiple instances according
to studies of racist discrimination per
day they don't understand what's
happening to them because nobody is
explaining it to them and no one's
sharing with them how to change the
world and and how to be a young
anti-racist does and you're eunuch the
story you wanted to tell I'm curious
about the conversation too that you and
your partner are having with your young
Sons yeah you know the story I wanted to
tell was the story that ibram told in
how to be an anti-racist it's his own
story it makes it very relatable his
willingness and his courage when it came
to just admitting that he had racist
ideas was was very helpful to me as I
was reading how to be an anti-racist and
we actually had an event last night in
Atlanta and we had a team moderator and
she was telling us how reading how to to
be a young anti-racist helped her to see
racist idea that she ideas that she has
right that's what we want young people
to experience we want them to be able to
identify with the story and also see
that they can change things
um and yeah my me and and the the father
of my children I have two the two boys
we we're real big on making sure that
they are both prepared for the world
they're in the world they're going to
enter but also empowered right like I
think that we can sometimes as black
parents and still a measure of fear that
trumps everything so making sure my kids
understand the world that they're going
to be in but also understand that they
do have the power to change it like
that's also what we're going for with
the book so yeah go ahead well I was
gonna say Abram you know there are a lot
of parents who think uh you know to
combat racism the old-fashioned way is
to not see race to treat everyone
equally to be colorblind but of course
one of the Bedrock principles of being
an anti-racist is that you are actually
color conscious talk to those parents
who think well a minute that's opposite
to what I want my kids to see
well I mean if if your child
does not see and understand difference I
mean in other words there are different
skin colors
and all those skin colors and all those
groups are equals uh then it's
incredibly important for them to see
that but they also see that certain
people have less
so they're trying to figure out why why
is it that black and brown people
disproportionately have have less in
this country and we need to explain to
them it's not because there's something
wrong with them it's because of racism
and here's how you join the struggle to
fight against it and you'd have a good
answer for that uh something very good
came out of you sliding into his uh DMS
you love her shirt I love your shirt we
need more things we need more and more
thinkers on all levels we sure do all
right even Max candy Nick Stone thank
you very much how to be a young
anti-racist goes on sale tomorrow